the democratic party in a comical chaos
after shellacking at the ballot box and
like joe biden going up a flight of
stairs they can't figure out how to go
forward
speaking of the president not taking any
blame and claims passing his absurd
agenda will solve the country's problems
with nancy pelosi hoping to save face so
she won't have to buy a new one
getting the job done producing results
for the american people is always very
positive the more results we can produce
in a way that is people understand in
their lives the better it is i was
really very unhappy about not passing
the biff last week and i thought that
that was
eloquent
but not enough i guess so now we're
gonna we're going to pass both bills
and after taking it on the chin
democrats are desperately trying to
spread the blame you see more finger
pointing going on than in an issue of
finger-pointing weekly
i hope it's a wake-up call for all of us
i'm concerned i've been talking about
our debt i've been talking about
inflation i've been talking about the
fallout we may have
this is not a center left or a left
country
we are a center if anything has a little
center-right country i think that the
results show
the limits of trying to run a fully 100
super moderated campaign that does not
excite
speak to or energize a progressive base
meanwhile skeletor lollipop democrat
james carville is shredding wokeness in
his pathetic little party
it's just stupid wokeness defund the
police luna cities take abraham
lincoln's name off of schools i mean
that
people see that
and it it it it's just really uh have a
suppressive effect all across the
country the democrats some of these
people that need to go to a woke detox
center it's true we need a woke decox
detox oh boy
jesse the problem is
first of all disavow the pelosi crack oh
stop it jesse senator manchin says this
is a wake-up call but you cannot wake up
the woke because by definition they're
already woke and they believe it's the
people like mansion the moderates and
everybody else on the planet who are
unconscious so you can never actually
have a wake-up call with the woke right
that's why it won't happen and here's
where we are right now the american
people are out to dinner and we are
starving but there is nothing on
joe biden's menu that we can eat we're
saying joe you got anything for gas
prices no anything for inflation no
supply chain no we're out of that but
would you like to hear the specials nah
joe's like uh yes um we have mandates
climate stuff roads and bridges and
government run babysitters and by the
way that's all going to be late because
the kitchen's a little backed up
that's what's happening right now all
right and now they're saying
you know what the american people are
upset because our agenda is not being
passed fast enough no no no
we
don't like your agenda because that's
not our agenda our agenda is can you
make our lives less expensive can we
make it less divisive maybe a little
more convenient no they can't they're
saying we can give you a place to plug
in your electric car no one owns an
electric car we don't even want that i
don't want one so do you know remember
bill clinton 92 he said what we're gonna
end welfare as we know it got elected
and went hard left gays in the military
hillary care got rocked in 94 and then
pivoted triangulated and won re-election
by saying the era of big government's
over who did that carville was his top
strategist because carville knows how to
read a room yeah he can see that people
like the police they respect the
founders they don't want to be called
racist because they oppose crt
and
right now aoc is in this little queens
bubble the met gala bubble the
washington dc social media bubble she
doesn't have a clue what the rest of the
country wants mansion knows mansion can
read the room so mansion wants to give
us what we want and aoc is not going to
let us have it
mansion has a lot of rooms
to read you know speaking of speaking of
division
that's the strategy dana of the
democrats the party is like a co-host
who buys everyone on the staff pizza
merely to point out that the other
co-hosts didn't buy the pizza like here
i am buying you pizza but they aren't
when she could have said why don't all
the co-hosts go in and buy the pizza
should i have asked you would you like
to pitch in no no no i don't know what
you're talking about we just wanted to
be asked but is it is it
i don't admit that no i didn't write the
note um anyway but we wanted to
congratulate our staff for our amazing
ratings i think what's the point of all
of that i think division is what is is
now we're tearing the party about i know
what the total thing was what it didn't
cost you anything yeah right it's just
like this bill right it's just like the
white house has said it's going to cost
you nothing that's true like and then
you get all the benefit it's like it's
amazing that's how it works i think the
democrats are in a rock
in between between a rock and a hard
place because if they
ignore the will of the voters that have
just spoken
then that will be bad for them but if
they don't press forward they will
literally have nothing to show their
base yes and in a midterm election you
ha you need your base to turn out so
i can see why somebody like aoc is
trying to make this point he's like you
know what you didn't get enough people
to turn out to care about the things
that you said you were going to run on
you haven't accomplished that and that's
why we lose manchin has a bigger
perspective which is like the health and
the well-being of the democratic party
for generations right
yeah geraldo yesterday you said this
wasn't really a big deal but you're
watching the democrats now to them it's
a big deal right
i
don't think so let me let me let me let
me tell you let me tell you when i was
growing up the
the two big parties democrat and the gop
had liberals moderates and conservatives
all of them different degrees different
percentages of course but they were
liberal republicans moderate democrats
and so forth
now
they're all
robots they're clones they follow in
lockstep to whatever the leader says so
then you have joe manchin who like liz
cheney is someone who stands up for that
what they believe in you may not like it
but they are principled people strip
away the bs all of this talk all of this
drama all of this vote tonight there's
no way joe manchin is going to vote for
bill back better it is no way he's not
going to get there
he hates it and he's been he's been
looking a million ways how to let them
down easily because he's uh he likes the
democrats but he is not one he's not
going there there's not going to be a
vote
on on bill that better and if there is
then he's going to go against it and
they wouldn't be surprised that kristen
cinema doesn't join him right and and
the they're going to lose in the senate
they may win in the house but i think
that if the senate doesn't go there then
the house might not either and
this is the audacious ploy
was the progressives who said
you can't have infrastructure if we
can't have
buildback better so they kept it hostage
they kidnapped the bipartisan
infrastructure bill that would have
given us bridges and tunnels and wi-fi
and so forth and so on
because they wanted to jam that and then
they lost now i i think aoc is as
charming and once in a generation and
you know but she ain't happening
substantive
so to geraldo's point judge
the democrats are electing the
republicans by their by their policies
there's no question about it did you say
aoc was charming
okay well okay well we'll pass that look
it's like the cookie jar right the mom
says who took the cookies she took the
cookies you took the cookies everybody
took the cookies it's like it's nobody's
fault the truth is it's all of their
fault they lost because number one they
can't get along with each other number
two they're creating this agenda and
this ideology that americans are not
high on number three they're creating
their own division and number four they
can't see what they did so they're gonna
keep losing and to your point yes they
will continue to elect republicans and
the real issue right now is what has
happened with this election the thing
that has happened is it's just not an
indication of what's going to happen in
22 and 24 possibly but they have put
together coalitions of different parties
who are interested in the issue of
schools and children and america and
working and people are crossing party
lines while the democrats can't even
stay together in lockstep pelosi says
she's going to get both pills bills
passed manchin says not so fast and then
you've got aoc saying we're way too
moderate i mean what should we
i can't imagine what she wants to do but
the bottom line is they're not going to
get them both past yeah there you go uh
coming up uh jesse and i will be
purchasing puppies for every member of
the five staff
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else